et on reçoit notre invité du vendredi
c'est pas mal ça le mot invités du
vendredi alain bonsoir bonsoir à
l'incognito alain cognard jeunes homos
g2 est magicien je suis illusionniste
prestidigitateur d'accord à otepää
magiciens ont tous dit en logiciels et
vous venez en plateau pour nous parler
d'un gala de magie que vous organisez
samedi soir alors à verneuil-sur-seine
passait pas tout à fait le secteur de
saint quentin en yvelines mais du coup
on vous a invité parce que c'était à la
fois pour parler d'une association qui
s'appelle les magiciens du coeur et puis
parler de ce gala avec un nom qui va
rattraper plein de souvenirs à plein de
gens je pense de ma génération gérard
majax gérard et j'ai à souhait vous vous
rappelez tous dès l'émission il ya un
truc c'était l'émission c'est qu'a duré
très longtemps qu'il qui a donné la
renommée monsieur gérard majax gérant
m'a jasant samedi soir à wana il sera
présent samedi soir il fait un spectacle
de 40 minutes quand même et
il est peu par un des magiciens du coeur
on va parler des magistrats du corps
mais d'abord pour donner envie aux gens
peut-être de faire pardonner on va
parler de ce gala il ya cinq magicien 5
magicien c'est la magie pendant toute
une soirée c'est que de la magie rien
que de la magie on l'amène des gens dans
le monde du rêve pendant toute une
soirée
c'est un gars là qu'a lieu dos comme
vous l'avez dit verneuil sur seine c'est
un gala qui va commencer à 21h la
première partie sera fait par des
magiciens qui interviennent dans les
hôpitaux plus voit aussi d'un mauvais tu
avais aussi dans les hôpitaux
il y aura un magicien professionnel un
deuxième est rationnel jb qui lui
travaille dans ce n'est dans les
cabarets à paris accueille c'est un
jeune magicien qui monte et qui a étonné
tout le monde d'ailleurs ce qui l'a
détour époustouflant et puis en deuxième
partie
gérard majax en australie tours de magie
classique ce qu'on appelle un tour de
magie classique ça sera les tours de
magie classique un peu de menthe alice
et on a deux magiciens qui intervient
dans les hôpitaux de poissy et de
versailles qui font la présentation
puisque vous parlez du saumon des
magiciens capables dans les hôpitaux
c'est le but de l'association les
magiciens du coeur alors paris nous
cette association
elle a été créée il ya combien de temps
et pourquoi alors cette association j'ai
eu l'honneur de la créé en 1977 pour
sauver la fille la vie d'un enfant qui
avait la leucémie
hague a lui il fallait de faire un don
de greffe ne trouvait pas de donneur de
greffe de moelle en france donc il
fallait chercher aux états unis et je
vous passerais tout est histoire mais on
est arrivés devrait avoir suffisamment
d'argent pour acheter une greffe aux
états unis parce qu'à l'époque pas
d'acheter les greffes aux états unis
ensuite bon bah ça s'est arrêté un petit
peu et moi je faisais l'hôpital de
garches de saint louis en tant que
magicien vous allez dans les hôpitaux
parce que la portée du sourire aux
enfants voient le rêve du rêve aux
enfants un peu de sourire un peu de joie
des fois ça aide les médecins souvent
même ça et des médecins parce que quand
un enfant 20
et heureux et ça va mieux et ça va
beaucoup mieux de suite quand il rentre
en salle d'opération s'il a rigolé avant
fond c'est formidable c'est plus facile
médecin c'est plus facile c'est fait
aussi pour l'enfant est effectivement
plus facile pour le personnel soignant
aujourd'hui ma la magie du coeur c'est
une association nationale vous avez
combien de magicien qui participent et
qui viennent alors nationale pas encore
tout à fait parce qu'on a mal en
bretagne bien sûr on abolit la
fédération france de magie qui a pris
les magiciens du coeur sous sa tutelle
et aides nationales
nous avons donc il ya plusieurs groupes
dont clown et magicien le coeur il ya
d'autres associations comme agir
l'hôpital que les mailles d'un autre
groupe de magicien qui travaillent eux
en province
nous on travaille surtout sur l'île de
france on les averses aille bien sûr
niño on l'est à poissy on les a mantes
la jolie on les a gâchées vous êtes
combien alors combien de magiciens ont
les une douzaine d'accords on se quitte
au magicien du coeur intervenants des
hôpitaux et du coup vous savez combien
d'enfants ont pu voir vos tours de magie
et combien mont houy une part amp une
mine punir par an d'accord mais alors
comment justement on arrive dans un
service avec des enfants qui sont
souvent en souffrance en tout cas qui ne
sont pas dans leur élément naturel
puisque ils sont à l'hôpital et comment
on fait pour les amuser pour les
intéressés ou alors d'office quand ils
vous voient arriver ils savent qu'il va
se passer quelque chose et c'est super
pour le premier point le magicien doit
redevenir un enfant
il est comme un enfant il n'est pas
supérieur il n'est pas inférieur il est
comme un enfant
et croyez moi les offenser des gens très
présente saison très très intelligente
et si on les bluffs c'est qu'on est con
n'est quand même pas trop mauvais en
magie c'est eux qui vont le plus rire
être direct au but faut devenir un
enfant l'aura mené il ya des enfants qui
nous disant moi la magie j'aime pas trop
et on leur fait un tour qui les bloque
du sweat et à partir de ce moment les
enfants qui vous disent qu'ils n'aiment
pas la magie m'étonne
les enfants qui savait à partir de 13
ans elle aime plus la magie disent que
c'est pour les petits ah oui et alors
que les adultes ils adorent ça
c'est un paradoxe non mais donc on leur
fait un tour a battu marc fait un autre
et à partir de ce moment là bas et c'est
marcher demain et alors vous qui avez
créé quelques fondateur de cette
association des magiciens du coeur est
ce que vous avez des souvenirs
particuliers d'échanger idées
je pense que ça doit être à chaque fois
différent la règle chaque enfant c'est
différent et pas de problème moi le plus
gros souvenirs j'ai c'est que j'étais
dans un hôpital que je vais dans une
chambre et on veut ni surtout tu fais
pas de sculpture sur ballons tu vas pas
le ballon ce qu'elle est allergique au
latex
c'est une petite fille qui avait une
grave maladie quand de vos paires et
d'après midi et je suis rentré dans la
chambre et j'ai dit qu'est ce que je
vais faire et j'ai dit je vais créer
qu'un tour shampoing de travail et je
vais être présenté avant de servir de
cobaye
je fais le tour et je me suis planté
mais bien et alain s'est mis à rire le
professeur qui ré l'opéra était dans le
couloir et rend-il qu'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui ou supporter je
loupais un tour hamdi meurs je me suis
aperçu qu alain c'est un match un homme
un magicien
c'est un homme comme un autre a dit la
petite fille je dis oui un des hommes
comme les autres
puis j'ai recommencé de louper ça marche
et elle n'avait pas vu truc elle a eu du
mat est planté et quand je suis sorti le
professeur m'a dit vous savez ça fait
trois mois qu'il est là la preuve à la
bouche ou aujourd'hui c'est la première
fois grâce à vous l avez réussi
bah oui ça l'est sortait de son
quotidien et dicale ce que nous ne
sommes pas des gens du service médical
ne sommes pas la famille parce qu'on
compte des gens qui sont sur des enfants
qui sont suicidés je rencontre qui
déprime et nous sommes et c'est pas
facile en plus d'arriver comme ça dans
un établissement hospitalier où
effectivement vous n'êtes pas de
formation médicale on en cubes il n'en
faudra obama oui enfin bon on n'est pas
là on n'est pas là pour soigner les
oranges et ses émotions quand même un
petit peu à l'extérieur parce que voilà
ça c'est plus dur c'est la sortie
d'hôpital grippe à l'entrée je présume
que ça va pas être facile sur ce gala de
magie et jordan magic a lieu samedi à
verneuil-sur-seine les fonds vous avez
collecté avec les entrées pour servir à
l'association vont servir à conserver à
l'association un servir à acheter des
tours de magie quand l'offre au moins
aux enfants qu'ils sont
une hospitalisation de longue durée
c'est-à-dire à garches à bullion donc
les enfants sont très longtemps on
achète des tours le wrestling détour
leur donne des pythies déclare vous
donnez vos secrets
on donne des secrets la magie ça donne
pas ses socles mais s'il ya des secrets
qui peut donner aux enfants d'avoir les
damnés corps vous savez quand je donne
même des gros secret à des enfants qui
sont en fin de vie
que voulez vous ça m'apporte ma nous en
coûte rien et c'est l'enfance hype et
cinq minutes de bonheur ses 5000 de
bonheur c'est important c'est important
alors vous êtes magiciens du coup vous
êtes venus nous faire un tour quand même
oui je pense que je dis oh bah j'ai
vraiment j'ai hésité un j'ai hésité
longtemps
même si j'ai trouvé je fais un tour avec
des cordes comme ceux-ci voyez donc une
corde rouge
sept corps de rouge on va faire un
cercle un cercle où ça me rappelle un
fils à un cercle rouge et vérifier un
cercle jaune et je fais des de mahradé
de plat et un cercle bleu
donc là je peux certifier il n'y a pas
de vie si je serre la vis et je peux
certifier qu'il ya bien des repos n'y a
pas de huissiers c'est moi qui descend
lundi vicié donc cercle jaune cercle
rouge un cocon a fait trois cercles 3
cercle magique vous savez dans le cirque
magie comme aj ça existe
on n'est pas des sorciers quand même
donc voici trois cordes
comment l'acheter en l'air j'ai bluffé
suis bluffé parce que franchement non
plus eu à j'ai pas un mètre de vous
alain engine et ça c'est bien sûr c'est
un tour qu'on fait avec trois corps mais
les cordes après c'est pas tout c'est
que quand on est tien comme ceux ci on
va essayer de l'est avec un souffle
magique de les retirer
ça c'est pas grand chose mais voulait un
souffle magique et les corps à corps on
fait bien voilà avec les cordes
excusez-moi de micro de corps il n'y a
pas de magie on peut pas couper et trois
corps ok parfait merci beaucoup d'être
venus et sur ses mac et vous remercie de
nous parler de ce leurre accueillez
notre association et oui donc ce gars là
je rappelle il a lieu samedi soir à
verneuil-sur-seine à l'espace et on est
servi dans les yvelines et on a ainsi
les magiciens du coeur au lavoir pour le
voir garder up et voilà on le voit donc
les magiciens du coeur une association
dont le magicien qui vient au service
des enfants malades avec un gala donc
samedi soir un espace maurice béjart de
verneuil sur seine merci à vous d'être
venu sur ce plateau